Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and um,
jazz checking in on
youuu
specifically the ladies.
I'm checking in on the ladies to make sure that you feel okay,
that you feel like you're in a safe space to listen to this podcast.
Not because I care,
because I want to start trending on Twitter.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ with the award shows in the fucking the same speech given every
awards show,
always called brave as if somebody's going to heckle it.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know,
like somebody that shut the fuck up and get out the shite there,
your log winded jacket.
Nobody's going to say that.
We're all going to sit there and be like,
wow.
That thing that was already said was just said again,
but this time it was said even better.
Hey,
keep saying the thing you already said.
I want to go out there and say the thing that was already said.
I want to be that person.
I wouldn't be brave.
You want to be brave.
You go the other way.
Listen,
I know there's a lot of guys out there took the dicks out at work,
but what about these gold digging whores?
Am I right fellas that now that would be brave.
Be Brave.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'd like to see you fucking walk out of that one.
Yeah.
MMM.
Saying the thing that's been said that everybody gets,
once again,
we'll be right back with the saying the thing that's always said at everything.
Now award show after these messages,
you know,
people,
while we were away,
something else was said that was already said that needed to be said again in
case anybody didn't hear it the first 19,000 times it was said.
MMM.
You know,
and like,
I swear to God,
and this is all it does,
is it just causes of copycat fucking behavior.
Same thing with these mass shootings,
you know,
which is why they should report on them because then everybody wants to do it.
Right.
Fucking some chick makes a porn and becomes fucking super famous.
Now every broad out there starts fucking dropping their panties.
I looked it up.
It happens.
Right?
So now fucking Pete is getting into it.
Yeah,
they're trying to say,
you can't say beat a dead horse and then they,
they came up with all this dumb shit.
There's no fucking way that this,
this can't be coming from Peter.
Like they said,
when it's raining out,
don't say it's raining cats and dogs that promotes violence towards,
it's just,
you know,
okay.
You know,
can you say it's a frog strangler?
MMM [inaudible]
you can't listen to Christmas music.
You know what I mean?
They're going to go through all of the catalog now.
That song I really cared.
Stay cause baby,
it's cold outside.
I really can't stay was saying that that promoted some sort of rape or then
don't under the apple tree.
What?
Anyone else?
What me that's controlling.
She can sit under whatever apple tree she wants to.
I think the meeting was that was,
hey,
don't go and fucking suck some other Dick while I'm off fighting war.
You know,
fight in a war here defending the country,
you know?
But you know,
you couldn't say that back then.
Right baby?
It's cold out or is it good?
I really can't stay baby.
It's cold outside.
I got to go away,
baby.
It's cold outside
this evening has been been hoping that you drop in.
So,
but it's,
it's,
it's such a cute fucking SOG.
There's a bunch of fucking songs out there that you could just turn into some
shit.
Right.
Um,
anyways,
needless to say,
that's my new walk on music when I do a stand up.
Sure.
You know,
it's funny,
I don't even like that song.
It's a fucking Corny God damn song.
I don't even fucking like it,
but I'm such a cunt,
you know?
Actually to be honest with you,
I think there needs to be some sort of turning down the spigot on this fucking
insanity because it's literally 8% of the population is acting like they're
speaking for or evidently babysitting the fucking rest of us.
But like I think I can listen to that song and not rape anybody.
I've done it for 50 years.
I'm going to go out on a limb and to think I'm going to be okay.
You know,
this goes like back to when they thought,
listen to Judas priest and all of that Shit,
you know,
made you go out and fucking kill yourself and do all,
which we all know is,
is it really comes down to just bad parenting.
Um,
it is a thing I know most women don't give a fuck about,
you know,
if you put on that song,
you know what I mean?
I know.
Okay.
I don't know.
Was it brave to do what I just did?
That's what you do.
You go on an award show,
you do a fucking tap dance.
Two,
I really can't stay.
And then you come out and you talk about gold digging whores.
MMM.
You know,
and then you'd try to like,
you go for the,
the anti that crowd.
I bet that could still fill in arena.
Right?
I'm sorry,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about here.
MMM.
Fucking Peta.
I love animals too.
Did you know how much of a dose you have to be for somebody to be behind your
cause and also to be sitting there going the ace people are fucking assholes.
MMM.
I think I just described myself as a person because my wife loves me,
but she really seems to side with other people a lot of the times,
you know?
Um,
so let's,
let's,
let's plow ahead here into the podcast,
into the podcast.
I want to thank everybody on the Seth Meyers show for having me on.
I had a great time promoting a season.
Three of F is for family as far as I can tell from the tweets.
It seems to be going really well.
People seems to be really enjoying it.
But why wouldn't they?
We already have a great cast.
We already have a bunch of murderers in the writers' room and we added Vince
Vaughn.
That's right.
Spoiler alert.
Listen closely,
Vince Vaughn,
you'll hear his voice or the character that he's doing on season three.
And I'm really excited that people are enjoying it.
And I just want to say right now to all the brave people out there that are
fighting out there to try and get Netflix.
I just want you to know that your voice is heard.
It's heard by me,
and that there's a bunch of people out there that love you when you try to sign
on and just,
you know,
try to stay positive.
Um,
I flew back from New York,
uh,
yesterday and I'm one of those,
one of the rare times of the year where you land over the water on a,
in at lax usually,
you know,
usually the winds coming in off the water,
so you take off and land into the wind.
But this is the time we actually became around landed.
It was pretty fucking cool.
Um,
except was too cloudy for me to see the approach.
You know,
I'm a fucking nerd when it comes to that stuff.
But anyways,
when I was on the plane,
I actually watched the premiere league soccer game.
I watched,
I watched a arsenal versus man United and I gotta Tell Ya,
I really fucking enjoyed the game.
You know,
and I'm starting to understand it.
I saw,
now I understand why
one thing was offsite.
Do you know when they all line up and they cover the junk and somebody tries to
fucking bend it like Beckham around them?
You know like that's stupid ass movie.
I never fucking saw they were saying that this,
they scored a goal on that.
Maybe they were off site.
It's basically any party,
a body that could score a goal if it's behind that line on the offensive.
If you're an offensive player.
So this guy went to go make a move and it's,
you know,
you lead with your head when you start to run and listen,
I don't know.
You're doing that dance underneath the stick there.
Right.
Um,
so I guess he was offsite.
So I guess I understand that it really takes away a lot of the excitement he
should be able to take off a little bit.
Why get it?
Cause they have to stand there and try to block it.
Yeah.
None of the offensive players,
you know,
they don't give a shit they want.
They're just going to take off.
Okay,
I get it.
Um,
but I gotta tell you something bad,
bad,
bad fucking defense in that Goddamn game.
Yeah.
You time Arsenal score.
Then they turn around,
they just fucking gave up another one,
that long fucking pass.
I don't know any of the terminology,
but I just know that that that shouldn't happen.
Sorry lolly gag and going after the ball and that little cut came running up and
kicked it in with his fucking toe hair.
That shouldn't happen.
Um,
but it was a,
it was a great game and um,
I dunno,
I haven't been drinking.
It just made me want to booze.
There's something about watching a premier league game at night.
It's always fucking raining.
It's always like misty.
It just looks like,
yeah,
I want to fucking start the fire and drink,
you know,
seven or eight pints.
Why wouldn't you?
The cell about saying a pint.
You feel like you're a fucking world traveler and you don't feel like you're a
fucking alcoholic.
Speaking of which,
I actually watched this thing on youtube called what kind of drink or am I that?
I'll be discussing what Joe de Rosa on uninformed the next episode I might
Patrion page and um,
I went and I looked up those alkie questions.
Yeah.
Cause this guy sounded like me.
Like,
you know,
I can stop when I want to.
I don't wake up shaking and I have to drink fucking booze.
I'm not an alcoholic.
What kind of drink or am I okay.
Are and I answered the questions dude.
All right.
Are you an El Co Hall?
Lik Alright,
here we go.
Here we go.
Drug addiction treatment.
Are you high functioning?
Uh,
wait,
I got to see.
Oh,
quiz,
alcohol problems.
Screening,
quiz.
Oh boy.
If I,
okay.
Question.
Wow.
Okay.
Do you sometimes drink more than you planned to drink?
Oh,
I don't have a plan other than I'm going out.
Let's see if I drink it all.
I have only one or two before dinner.
Okay.
I hope any joke I tell tonight we'll be funnier than that line.
No,
that's not me.
I will occasionally skip or delay meals to have a couple more drinks.
Uh,
well I've drank for a period where I didn't realize.
I mean I drink until I'm hungry,
you know,
and then I can get a slice at the end of the night.
Wait,
sometimes a few with the boys slash girls turns into an entire evening.
Well,
I never just go out for a few.
I go out with this specific,
um,
I go out to get hammered.
I've been on benders that lasted for days.
No,
I haven't done that.
I mean,
I,
my,
unless you call consecutive nights of drinking,
but I mean,
I sober up and be like,
oh,
what am I doing?
And then the next night I have another one.
All right.
Do you sometimes drink more than you planned to drink,
if at all?
Uh,
occasionally skip.
Sometimes.
I guess the closest one was,
would be the third one.
C sometimes a few with the boys slash girls turns into an entire view.
Yeah,
that's fair.
All right,
let's check that.
Yeah.
Did the end of this quiz.
Someone's trying to make money off of me so you know,
I'm going to flunk it and I need their help.
All right.
Have you ever tried to quit drinking and were unsuccessful?
I don't want to quit.
I enjoy an occasional drink.
I've thought about quitting,
but I've just gotten around,
but I haven't got around to it.
I've tried to control my drinking,
but it hasn't worked for very long.
I've tried to quit drinking many times.
Uh,
I go on sabbaticals.
I like,
I need to shut it down
and I've been able to do that,
but then I just get bored.
I just get poured and I,
you know,
like what am I never going to have another drink?
So I guess I've tried to my drinking and it hasn't worked for very long.
Well,
I've gone a year.
Right.
How much time do you spend each week drinking?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
I only drink on special occasions at,
no,
no.
I only drink on weekend and I drank at least three nights a week.
Now we're getting there.
I drank almost daily.
As soon as I get off work.
Ding,
Ding.
All right.
Do you have an,
do you ever get an urge to drink or a craving for alcohol?
Yes.
Okay.
No,
I can take it or leave it.
Jesus Christ.
Somebody works at a library.
All right.
Sometimes if I've gone a few days without a drink,
I'll get a desire to drink.
Yes.
If I skip a day drinking,
I'll have an urge to drink the next day.
No,
I can't wait until happy hour every day.
I'd say to,
uh,
the second one.
Number five.
Oh,
Billy booze hound.
He's almost halfway there.
Right.
How many fucking questions are there?
11.
Do you have to get bored taking multiple choice questions?
No.
Do you often miss work or school or obligations that no.
I don't ever remember.
Miss?
No.
I've never,
I've never
now,
no.
Never.
I'm a pro.
I wait till after the work's done.
Uh,
has your drinking negatively effected your social or family relationships?
No.
I rarely drink enough to become intoxicated.
Sometimes I haven't embarrassed myself while drinking.
Yes.
I prefer to hang out with people who drink as much as I do.
To that.
I have lost friends relationship?
No,
it's somewhere between B and C in.
Sometimes I have embarrassed myself while drinking and I also prefer to hang out
with people who drink as much as I do.
Um,
so I guess I picked the worst of the two.
That's only fair.
Have you given up hobbies or activities you used to enjoy?
No.
Alcohol doesn't interfere with my life.
No,
it doesn't,
I think,
am I functioning?
Does your drinking ever put you in a dangerous situation?
When I drink it's only at home.
Uh,
that's not true.
I have had a couple of drinks at lunch.
No return to work.
I've drank.
I have drinking.
I've driven after drinking before,
but I was not really drunk,
bad back in the day before I got arrested when I was 21.
I regularly drive home from the bar.
No,
I don't drive home.
So where do I go with that one?
I have driven after drinking before,
but I wasn't,
not really drunk.
Well,
I've done that.
Yeah.
You wait till you're sober.
I'll click on that one.
Has drinking caused you any persistent health problems now?
Uh,
all right.
There we go.
Does alcohol still give you the same feeling?
One drink helps me relax.
Yeah.
Three beers used to do it.
Now it takes a six pack.
I changed to liquor because wine wasn't giving me a buzz.
I changed the liquor cause for the out for the calories.
Thought it was,
you know,
I mean I know they all have calories but I figured I'm just got a little shot
glass of it's supposed to 12 ounces.
Um,
alcohol still give you the same feeling?
Well,
I guess the closest one had one.
One drink helps me relax.
Um,
but I have changed the liquor cause wine wouldn't give me a buck.
Well would,
but I have to drink too many and then I get like fucking acid reflux with that
shit.
All right.
When you go out.
Yeah.
Um,
without alcohol,
do you get withdrawal symptoms now?
I don't feel any negative.
All right,
so now what does that mean?
Could you have an a,
you got a moderate alcohol problems?
Well,
I could have fucking told you that.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
no,
I've been a,
I've been a good boy.
I haven't drank since the end of fucking November.
I'm coming up on two weeks.
You know what?
I'm doing it during the holidays and everybody's like,
lane am around,
ain't doing that.
I got to get in shape for this fucking European run that I'm doing.
European run.
Bill,
you don't say I've seen it on your website,
boy.
Oh boy.
A lot of them sold out.
Any chance that he had his second shows in some cities.
Why yesterday?
January 5th,
Munich second show,
uh,
January six often buck,
they added a second show.
Uh,
January 8th and Raga Riga Modal.
They added a second show,
Vienna,
they added a second show.
Liverpool,
my adopted fucking premier league team,
I think.
I Dunno.
I got,
I got to pick a team,
but I think it's gotta be them and I'm doing it because I liked the Beatles.
Uh,
London,
they added a second show,
March 5th,
Copenhagen,
Denmark,
April 30th and Helsinki,
they edit a second show.
I love it.
All right.
Oh,
daddy's going to be over there fucking working.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's why I cut it off.
I,
I got some sort of fucking issue goes last night I was sitting by the fire with
my wife.
I'd let you know,
put the Christmas lights on the tree and all of that shit.
We're having a great time.
I love the holidays.
So she goes,
you want some eggnog with a little in there,
you know,
she says,
and I said,
Nah,
I'll just take the eggnog.
But I,
you know,
a little bit of a,
what's that shit you put on top of it?
The brown stuff,
not make a little nutmeg on top and I'll be good excuse.
Can't have just a little bit.
I go,
no,
because then I'll want to have a bunch more and then that could turn into a,
you know,
me drinking every night for the next week or for the next year.
Just about,
you know,
I'm a habit guy and if I'm not drinking I,
I,
I'm either on or fucking off.
I be honest with you,
I lost that to kind of just like,
you know,
occasionally have a beer.
I have to like be not doing it or fucking doing it now.
I cannot do it.
I guess
stirfry free time,
man.
I got too much fucking free time.
Um,
okay.
If I had like an,
you know what,
I need this.
I think the biggest problem with my Busan is,
is I don't,
I,
there's no rules.
That's all I need because with like cigars,
I have rules,
you know,
as far as to how many I'm going to have a,
I just have to have rules with alcohol.
So maybe like I was thinking what if like,
uh,
two Saturdays a month,
you know,
that would be perfect cause then I'd still go out and get to drink cause I
fucking love booze,
but then I won't be like negatively affected myself.
Um,
you know,
I also won't be bored shitless and they also won't be a bloated fuck.
So maybe in,
I feel like in a,
when I do the European tour,
maybe the second to last night just so I'm not hung over for the flight or
whatever.
No,
cause I know me.
Then I'll be like,
oh my God,
this flight's fucking long as shit.
Why don't we just have fucking three doubles real quick and just pass out.
Wake up over fucking Greenland.
It'd be like,
yeah,
fuck.
We only have,
we did man.
Um,
whatever.
I'll figure it out.
Um,
let's see here.
Maybe I'll go to an AA meeting.
Every time I go to a fucking AA meeting like Jesus Christ,
he's fucking,
people are crazy.
I just sit in a bar and drink and I get hammered and then I fucking go home.
That's it.
You know,
there's no cops.
There's no fucking family fucking coming down there
like these fucking stories.
Um,
there's no blood
jail and shit.
All right,
butcher box.
Everybody.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread,
pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets,
starts with the commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they're murdered.
Cook with the piece to cook with the peace of mind knowing you're eating
healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least 18 to 11 pounds of meats,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you a gluttonous fat fuck,
you know you probably burned through it faster than I do a bottle of booze.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken beef mixed box custom box.
Let you choose your own cuts.
Incredibly convenient.
Think of butcher box as your neighborhood butcher delivered right to your door
on dry ice for free shipping anywhere in the 48 states.
Choose your delivery frequency with the customizable subscription for Free Bacon
and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter burr at checkout.
All right.
Oh look,
Hosea Dotomi [inaudible] ds beyond ease was in that fucking brave Doo Doo doot
doot Miyon ds me on days.
Don't go to a fucking rave and drop fucking Molly and stand dog next to a creep.
Next thing you know his balls are in d mag show.
You look out for yourselves this holiday season,
especially if they play baby,
it's cold outside.
I'm talking about.
Alright me undies,
every body soft as a fucking deers ass arraigned.
Deers asks,
have you finished your holiday shopping yet?
No worries.
You can get everything you need for your loved ones at me.
Undies me undies uses the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
If you never felt this fabric,
get ready to experience pure bliss and underwear form.
You can also get a style that is perfectly suited for you or that special
someone,
men and women can choose from four different cuts,
all of which are available from classic colors too.
Adventurous prints,
but my balls are cold outside but wide stop at the undies.
Me undies has cozy lounge pants in onesies in that same super soft fabric.
Perfect for wearing.
My balls are fucking cold,
uh,
for wearing Christmas morning offer me,
Andy says,
had a great offer for my listeners for any first time purchasers.
Uh,
you're with your,
when you purchase any me undies,
you get 15% off and free shipping order by 12,
16 for free shipping in time for Christmas crunched for time.
You can't go wrong with the me undies gift card.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to get
50% off your first pair of free shipping and 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr and lastly,
but not leastly helps everybody.
You ever wake up in the morning with regrets of what you'd done?
Yeah.
A Re replaying the terrible decisions you made the previous night over and over
and over.
Yeah.
The kicking,
the sweating,
the yelling.
Yeah.
Whatever else you do to piss everyone off in the room.
Well guess what,
Bud?
Just deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
Uh,
well,
where would you buy something that you would enjoy it while you're in luck?
Because he likes sleep.
The mattress,
um,
I'm yelling at you about for almost two years will change your life.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the perfect mattress.
It's like Tinder for a,
for finding a mattress,
all the fun with none of the next morning regrets,
misery.
And right now you can get up to $125 off your mattress order at helix,
sleep.com/bar.
They have 101 hundred night trial,
free shipping and won't send you creepy next day texts.
That's healing.
sleep.com/burr for up to $125 off your first mattress order.
All right.
By the way,
that George Bush book that I was telling you where it talked about him flying
and all of that shit that was called fly boys,
not flags of our father.
It's fucking hilarious.
I barely,
yeah,
read.
I know it's not a surprise.
Um,
and I can't even remember the name of the Goddamn book than I fucking red.
That was the one with the George Bush stories that,
but you know,
I,
I didn't feel too bad that I picked the other book too,
cause they're both incredible books.
Um,
all right,
what else do we got here?
Uh,
let's see.
Award show speeches,
talked about that,
or subtle menus at the mayas Christmas tree.
No booze.
Oh,
oh,
whoa,
whoa.
I told you,
I'm thinking about switching to smoke in a pipe.
Both my grandparents smoked a pipe and they're dead now,
so I think it's a good note kit.
Um,
I should've been thinking about doing that.
I like it.
I like the whole fucking ritual.
It just seems really cool.
Sit down,
packing the thing,
lighten it,
having to relight it,
pack it down with that little fucking thing,
cleaning it out,
the whole goddamn thing.
Um,
somebody get,
when I was in,
of course,
one of my favorite cities of all time,
Milwaukee,
Wisconsin,
I was there and they gave me a pipe,
you know,
and I just,
I lost the thing and I just recently founded it.
Let me,
let me,
let me see.
I got it right over here next to the ball and like things here.
There's,
all of my things are out here.
Wait a minute.
With a flare.
It is,
let's see what I got in here.
Is it just the pipe?
What?
I have the little,
the little packer thing,
like I don't know the name of all this.
I also like,
you know what I like about cigar smoking and,
and also,
uh,
smoking a pipe is,
it's really fucking obnoxious.
Like cigar smoke is just because it's just all encompassing and nobody can get
away with,
get away from it.
All right,
so I've got a pipe.
I have some pipe cleaner and then do I have in here?
Do I have a little fucking,
oh,
I still got to buy the thing to pack it down.
Oh my God.
Dude,
are you serious?
I gotta.
I gotta try this fucking thing out,
you know?
Oh,
there's a little thing for that,
that I watched this whole thing,
like I,
first of all,
I noticed people who smoked pipes have crazy facial hair.
Like,
I don't know if I'm going to fit in.
Like when I show up and go,
that is a Newbie look at him.
He doesn't look like he,
uh,
you know,
he's a conductor or something like that.
Now Jesus,
you know what I want for Christmas?
I,
I really have to fucking fix this.
Fucking God damn headphones here.
Why do I do this to myself?
What is,
you know,
it's gotta be this adapter thing.
That's what it is.
I just have to buy a nice one.
Yeah.
I'm literally,
I'm handling this right now.
I'm going not right now,
but the podcast is over in a couple minutes and then we have some greatest hits,
another half hour.
So please by all means.
Okay.
This is a safe space to listen to a podcast.
Um,
anyways,
I,
I'm going,
I'm going to order one of those goddamn things.
Then I also got a bunch of nieces and nephews and they're all getting Boston
fucking sports shit.
All right,
I don't want to hear it.
Okay.
That's it.
I care
about sports.
Therefore you're going to care for two and stuff.
Speaking of which,
let's see when Liverpool's next game is
Liverpool.
Uh,
Come on.
Cause you know what?
I have the whole fucking month off and by the,
I just be by that I just mean I'm not going to fucking,
oh,
it always goes to fucking Wikipedia.
Jesus fucking Christ.
These cunts.
When the fuck did Google become set?
Why do I care?
Why do you care?
Who gives a fuck?
Premier Li,
they go premiere league daily.
Come on now.
Come on.
Gimme a break here.
All right.
They beat Fullam to nothing.
They beat Everton one nothing.
The next game is Saturday 4:30 AM
Jesus Christ.
Fuck.
Am I going to watch that?
They got man United coming up.
That's gotta be a big one.
Sunday the 16th
Oh shit.
All right,
well let's see what is,
what step fucking.
That's it.
They play once every 10 days.
I can't be right.
That can't be right.
All right,
I'm clicking on Liverpool three to one stat timeline.
See,
everything's different in another fucking timeline.
What the fuck does it do?
How do,
how do I get scheduled?
All right,
let me hit pause here.
Sorry.
Hold on.
All right.
Yeah.
Did these Games a nice and spread out?
Jesus Christ.
This is fucking easy to follow.
All right,
so what do we got?
They got one on Saturday.
Then they got Saturday the eighth and they got Sunday the 16th
then they got the 21st and the 26th
then the 29th oh by,
if I watch all of those games,
I'll be on board.
All right.
That'd be great.
With Liverpool on,
on one of these tours coming up,
you know,
I'm also doing Manchester City,
so Jesus Christ,
they'll get a bunch of shifts.
They don't give a fuck.
Right?
I'm just his stupid yet because then I could give a shit.
Just be happy.
I'm watching.
They won't give a shit.
The perfect scenario would be if I become a Liverpool fan and then they lose
demand city.
Right.
So then like Liverpool,
people will be happy that I'm rooting for their fucking team.
Then man,
see,
won't give a fuck because my team didn't win bill.
I don't think they're going to give a fuck either way.
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
I'm so psyched to be home.
I'm so fucking psyched to be home.
I have the best fucking life in the world.
Get married was the smartest thing I ever did,
could skid considering all the pitch and I do about it.
It's fucking great.
I'm going to go inside.
Go have a nice fucking ah,
get out of the garage here,
calling to get a nice fucking warm meal here.
Sit around the God damn Christmas tree,
right.
Have a good time.
And in the meantime we're going to be listening to this,
a little bit of fucking music here and then a half hour of greatest hits from a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from earlier this year or years ago.
I have no idea,
by the way.
Uh,
thank you to everybody that bought tickets to Patrice O'Neil comedy benefit on
February 19th,
2019 it's just about,
uh,
I think just about soul died,
a couple hundred left.
I have to keep promoting it of course.
Um,
and that is it.
All right,
go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on,
you know,
oh wait,
I'm sorry.
Today's Thursday,
right?
Have a great weekend.
You [inaudible] that's what I'm supposed to say and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Hello.
I've got all these,
hi,
wait a second.
The podcast isn't over yet.
I was supposed to do an inch after the music.
There's gonna be a little clip from one of the uninformed episode three,
I believe from the Patrion page.
Give you a little taste.
They're like a drug dealer will hopefully make you go to the fucking patriot and
listen to the rest of it.
So here it is,
me and all Joe de Rosa,
the teen idol sensation from the bay,
the opiate Anthony Program.
Uh,
talking about,
uh,
I think we're talking about being up.
Me Being a dad
on this one.
I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
All right.
Enjoy it.
[inaudible] a bit.
This fall called women's ways.
The trap you,
Dan
[inaudible] show less
the beauty.
Awesome joke.
God bless the people that love those things.
You know,
those are the kinds of people that fucking decorate their house on the holidays.
Neil loves him knee as a fucking best and he is going to fucking,
you know,
deck the hall.
She's going to deck the halls.
I'll tell you right now,
Joe,
I'm going to throw up my back pushing my fucking trash cans to the corner
because there was fold with like $300 with the fucking Pumpkin's that she bought
it for fucking
um,
Halloween and Thanksgiving and it looked great.
Joe.
I like Martha Stewart would have walked in,
she would have been nervous and like,
oh shit,
this,
this chick is coming.
Right.
Then at the end of the day,
they got a fucking,
you know,
they gotta go out to the curb.
I was sitting there like to,
I never get one.
I'm like,
I'm just going to have to throw it away.
It felt like there was a fucking dead body in there.
Dude.
It was like,
wait,
as much as a person,
I never get one cause I'm gonna am I gonna and then I also never put my up
[inaudible] think if you did stuff like that,
maybe you could sleep a little better.
Dude,
listen,
I love nothing more than,
than putting the tree up and decorated for Christmas.
Here's why I don't do it yet.
Dolls with balls of Holly follow La la La
got balls bells.
What a bells.
Bells that they're like shaped by Holly.
Bells are shaped like fucking people.
They're trying to get the quarters.
We are.
Those are army people later on.
What branch they were in.
Dang to Dang.
Dang.
You know those guys at the mall?
No,
that's no.
Holly Bill The fucking Green Shit with the berries on it.
Holly,
are you saying those ELLs?
Yeah,
they're called bells of Holly.
Like the things that you hang up,
those little bunches of Holly.
Oh,
I always had it.
I just thought it was literally bell's first.
I thought it was balls.
Maybe it means bells go.
I gotta be honest.
I'll shoot it my way through.
I think that's what it is.
Fluid.
And we've got to look up this fucking Joe is,
has there ever been a fucking show named more perfectly uninformed.
I took a wild swing,
but I have a feeling of working title was dumb fucks.
That's gotta be,
it's gotta be what it is though.
Bells of Holly like,
like,
uh,
like bales of Hay or you know,
what the fuck does,
hey,
you have to do with Holly.
I'm saying it's like the term,
like how you call a thing,
a hay bale of Hay.
All right.
I think you just call it a bell of Holly.
You know,
a Bushel of fruit.
In other words,
you know the everything,
so many shape bushels out there for me.
If you don't know what it means to bill,
you've been sharing your Bushel for years.
Oh,
I had to it.
Ah,
we're both wrong.
Deck the halls with Bose of Holly,
B o u g h n s o bows
la La la La la La la La.
It is the season to be jolly.
Follow La la
La la La la La Dawn.
We now are gay pair
la La la La la La la La.
Good little run DMC there.
Wait a second,
Don.
We are done.
We are gone.
Dude.
Don't talk about George.
You dawn means put on our gay apparel meeting.
Joyous,
festive,
mean something on a bill's closet.
Go a zigzag zoo,
troll the H and Yuletide tide.
Carol,
I never got what that meant through.
This is like how much English language changes.
This is like what the F,
I don't know what they're talking about here.
Let's see here.
You know somebody did like a metal versions of this dude.
It's sick.
Yeah,
the all with Paul De.
Alright,
are we?
Oh
what the fuck is a bow I bow definition where the bow like tea,
like a boat.
It's not o.
It's a main branch of a tree.
A branch of limb and Ah Dude.
That's where a bow and Arrow comes from.
I bet.
Because you would take a tree branch feel w you
sure?
Positive mom.
Now I mean I'm just saying it is hot.
It's how I spell it.
Bow and Arrow.
Yes.
Definition of above.
Jesus.
Joe.
We're just learning stuff,
right and left Bo definition a man,
a male,
white male from the south.
Hey Bo,
get over.
Sorry.
A not tied with two loops and two loose ends used specifically to tie shoe less
not in a weapon for shooting arrows.
Typically made of a curved piece of wood who's ends are joined together by a
touch string.
All right,
and that's bow.
Yep.
All right.
[inaudible] comes Joey d right down.
Joey d laying.
These guys have God.
All right.
Um,
that's uninformed.
Joe.
I like the,
we sang a little holidays.
Let's,
let's walk.
let's end this.
It's,
it's the holiday season.
I don't know that Warren Dooby dooby do.
Totally bought.
Which what is that?
Don't take out yet?
Cock at the Christmas party or you get me to,
um,
keep your an egg nog in your pants.
Yeah.
So don't walk up and grab her tits unless she tells you to
be safe and don't do it.
Have A,
walked those titties and it your fucking hands and then take a stroller in the
snow.
And then why do you know you're going to fuck her in the air?
It's the most wonderful time.
Oh Wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built Burt's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December six,
2010 I'll come.
I can't fucking hear myself just going on here.
Hello?
Hello.
Yeah,
mother fucker.
What is going on?
Hello?
Hello.
Hello,
hello.
All the levels seem right.
The fuck am I doing wrong lately?
I used to have this shit down.
Well,
I hope it's all right because it's late in the day and I have a football game to
watch.
Patriots are playing the jets,
you know those two fucking teams up and talking up out for fucking 19 weeks in a
row.
Uh,
they're playing tonight.
So I gotta fucking hustle through this thing because I'm doing this thing late
cause I just flew back from San Francisco.
I left my balls.
San Francisco.
Isn't that all the song goes?
Tony Bennett comes out,
luck be a lady to night.
Um,
that's Frank Sinatra.
Go Fuck yourself there.
Crooner fans.
What do think about that during the holiday month,
as you can tell,
I,
um,
I blew out my voice when I was doing cobb's club up in,
uh,
San Francisco.
And,
uh,
I had a great fucking time.
I'm 51 days without drinking and I got to tell you,
that's,
um,
San Francisco was one of those cities that makes you want to drink.
You know,
it was just an awesome city.
You go up there,
uh,
that's two weekends in a row.
I've absolutely loved the city Seattle last week and now San Francisco this week
in San Francisco.
It's really,
I don't know how people stay sober there because every time you walk around the
corner you just see one of those bars.
You know,
it's just got that warm old
dingy,
but it's got some character and he just want to fucking go in there and get a
pint and just start talking some shit,
you know,
fucking cold and rainy there the whole fucking weekend.
So psyched to be back in La those first time.
I've seen the sun in like 10 fucking days.
It feels like,
look at me with the potty mouth this week.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah,
I was up there and I worked cobb's comedy club and I want to thank all those
people who came out to see me.
It was ridiculous turnout.
Uh,
carbs is a,
uh,
it's a giant room for a comedy club and the place was packed the entire weekend
and uh,
it was great.
Everybody was showing up.
A bunch of people came up and told me that they loved the podcast and I had like
five people come up to me and tell me how much they liked the,
uh,
Socorro work.
They love it.
So I'm thinking actually turning that into a bit,
stick it into my act.
Um,
I just don't know if it's gonna work cause uh,
I think maybe if I stick my mouth close enough actually know.
And I listen.
Listen back to the podcast,
it sounded like the,
uh,
it sounded like the same sort of distortion.
I got to try it out.
I really got to fucking try it out.
You know what?
There's a rum out here called,
uh,
the comedy union,
used to be called mixed nuts.
It's called the comedy union is down on Labrea and uh,
well it's awful.
Labrea can't remember.
It's right down the street from uh,
uh,
Roscoe's waffle house,
chicken and waffles.
Roscoe's chicken and waffles.
Huh?
African-Americans.
You listen to the podcast,
there's a big shout out to that fucking restaurant.
Uh,
but anyways,
it's a club.
Um,
you know,
any comedian can go down there,
but it's a predominantly black audience.
Remember that from the news?
They used to say that all the time,
but predominantly black neighborhood,
predominantly black
neighborhoods.
So that's like put the crowds are so whenever I have a joke like that,
I like to go down to rooms like that or maybe do Tuesday night at the comedy
store because I want to make sure that a,
I'm saying the shit the right way.
You know,
granted that opens the door to some awkwardness if it doesn't come off the right
way.
But that's the fun of doing what I do.
So may have been going to head down there and speaking Roscoe's chicken and
waffles.
I heard so much about that shit.
A so called white man heard so much about that ship from the predominantly black
comedians
always hyping that place up.
You got to go down there.
You got to go down there and I got to tell you something.
I like chicken and I like Waffles,
but I do not like that shit together.
All right.
At no point in my life did syrup ever need to touch a chicken?
It's a,
it's fucking gross.
And uh,
I went there once and I'll never go there again.
Was One of those,
uh,
you have to go to like a soul food place and it's like fucking like hardcore
African American and you feel foolish as you're ordering cause everything's
named after like some civil rights leader.
Uh,
you know,
welcome to Roscoe's chicken.
Walter's going to take you on it.
Yeah.
Let me get the,
uh,
Frederick Douglas a Chili fries at,
can I get the,
uh,
Medgar Evers,
at a mommy?
Whatever the fuck.
Um,
you just feel dumb saying so I don't know if it's that bad where the file was at
.
Amy Ruth's,
we're going back in my career here,
back in my career when I used to,
uh,
I used to fucking jump over on both sides of the fence all the Goddamn time.
Back in the good old days,
there was,
that was a period in my career where I made sure that I,
uh,
on a regular basis when I was trying to figure out how to say what,
you know,
these glorious Dick Jokes and shit jokes that I do on stage.
There was a period during my career when I would,
when I would,
uh,
I would do all the rooms,
I could get in front of all the crowds.
And if you're a comedian,
I suggest that you do that cause it can do nothing but help you.
And um,
you know,
if you're really,
you know what I mean?
I learned that shit cause I saw Eddie Murphy on the raw tour way back in the
day.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield,
danger fields.
There was two of them,
Rodney Dangerfield.
And then two weeks later I say Eddie Murphy on the raw tour.
And I was like,
fuck at 18 years old.
And I remember looking at Eddie's crowd versus a Rodney's crowd.
And for some fucking reason that just clicked to me like Rodney's hilarious.
But Eddie is making everybody laugh.
So I remember,
uh,
kind of knew I wanted to be a comedian at that point,
but it took me another few years to get the balls,
you know,
to go on stage.
And then I'll say,
I had this fucking thing in my head that,
you know,
I had to make sure I finished college,
got to make sure I got tens of thousands of dollars worth of debt worth of debt.
So then I can then go on stage and talk about my Dick,
right.
To make my life even more difficult.
Um,
look,
I'm not saying whether or not you should go to college or you shouldn't,
but,
uh,
if you will like me and you just fucking knew,
you know,
you looked at standup comedy and you just,
you just fucking knew.
Uh,
I,
I don't think it would be the worst thing if he just said to hell with the next,
you know,
$40,000 worth of debt.
But who the fuck am I?
Who am I to say that?
How far are we into the,
ah,
seven minutes in seven fucking minutes.
And I got to tell you,
oh my God,
I'm fucking red line.
And on
the Shittier I'm seven minutes in,
I don't think I have anything left to talk about.
I am so fucking frazzled because I,
I don't know what happens when I fly back on the day of a podcast.
It's just,
I don't have any funny,
is no funny in me right now.
I'm just sitting here like I might as well be on meet the press.
You don't talking about budgets for the upcoming fiscal year?
Uh,
uh,
did anything interesting happened to me in San Francisco?
Of course not.
I wasn't drinking.
I'll tell you that.
I went out and I tried a bunch of food up there and I'll,
this is something I can guarantee you.
All right.
If you like a Burrito,
go to San Francisco.
Those guys,
I had a Burrito when I was up in San Francisco.
I've been thinking about,
I'm always fucking thinking about it before even said what I just said.
I've been thinking about this shit.
Like,
you know,
you have of just bang some fucking just,
some girl you never get to marry,
but she,
I dunno what she does.
I don't want to get graphic.
I try to stay away from the sex ship,
but you know,
and you just cared.
Stop fucking think it and your brain's going,
don't go back to her.
She's out of her fucking mind.
She's like,
that's not a mother.
It's not a mom.
You're not going to marry her.
Don't fucking go back.
But what she did on the other side,
right.
Come on.
We're all adults.
You know what I'm talking.
You can't stop fucking ticket about it.
I had the food version of that and God dammit,
it was a Burrito in San Francisco in like a fucking asshole.
I can't even tell you where I got it.
Uh,
I guess I can go a,
I can go on the Internet here and try and find it.
By the way,
here's a youtube video for you.
I'm a huge Stevie Ray Vaughan fan.
Huge Stevie Ray Vaughan Fan.
And,
uh,
he did a cover of an Albert King Song called,
a,
I just say any kind of give up on love,
but it's ain't gone in,
give up on love.
Uh,
I'm too white to say it that way.
So I say,
I ain't going to give up on love.
And the guy who put it up is a SRV music like Stevie Ray Vaughan music video,
SRV music video.
Um,
you put it up like a year ago for some reason I missed it.
And uh,
you gotta see this if you're a fan of guitar playing,
even if you don't like Blues Guitar.
Stevie Ray Vaughn,
he gets like three quarters of the way through his second blistering solo and he
fucking does this little spin move on,
does the fucking guitar straps in unal the guitars behind them,
straps the fucking guitar back on and proceeds to finish the solo behind his
back.
And not only is he playing with the guitar behind his back,
he takes the solo to a whole nother level beyond the Stevie Ray Vaughan level.
He was just at,
it's the fucking,
like,
if somebody could show me anybody who can play behind their back with that level
of passion,
that fucking good.
I mean,
I don't even know if Hendrix could do that.
Hendrix used to fucking,
I mean,
I know Hendrix is a better fucking guitars.
I'm not even going to start that fucking argument.
All right.
That's like compare and Jordan to Coby.
I get it.
I'm not even trying to say it before we even have this fucking argument.
Jimmy is,
yeah,
you can't even touch that guy.
But I'm just saying he took that,
that you know,
that stage trick to a whole nother fucking let's just watch it and actually if
you can find me one,
uh,
Jimmy doing it better,
which I'm sure you can,
maybe I haven't looked hard enough.
I'd love to see it because I get fucking chills watching this shit.
So anyways,
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to get rid of this screen here.
I'm going to find the name of this fucking burrito place because it was,
it was fucking amazing.
Um,
now I can't look for this as I'm doing this podcast.
Isn't this going to get boring for you guys?
Huh?
How's,
I'm typing with my middle fingers.
Cisco Years Funny About People in San Francisco and where every time I go there
is somewhere I either read or somebody tells me that nobody calls the city San
Fran.
And I really want to tell him that nobody I know calls it San Fran.
We just say San Francisco.
We don't call it Frisco either.
Like you fucking hit people in San Francisco.
We don't call it,
we just say fe San Francisco.
Go to San Francisco.
I wouldn't say I'm going to shy instead of Chicago would I?
I guess people say shy town.
All right,
here we go.
I am fucking zeroing in where I got this God Damn Burrito.
I'm going to find this.
Somebody,
one of the satellite like the fucking Illuminati does.
You know that when they're staring at you,
watching you fucking rubbing one out,
saving the video.
So if you ever go against,
all right,
it's on,
uh,
you motherfucker,
give me the satellite.
Come on,
give me that shit.
Don't you like how the Illuminati is allowed us to do this too,
so it won't seem as creepy when they'd fucking do it to us.
Is that it?
All right.
There you go.
I got it.
It's on a,
you can't you fucking cunt.
There it is right there.
It's on ninth avenue and Irving Street.
All right.
Just beyond Yancey saloon on that side of the road,
you walk down,
you make a right on nine fucking avenue.
Now we take the little yellow man,
the little Asian Dude,
right?
Is that always supposed to be?
Huh?
Put him down on the street.
Look at me and there's where the fuck I was slowly going down the street isn't
as exciting,
isn't this is what you get when you get a free fucking podcast.
You get absolutely no.
They'll get a poodle that the satellite took a picture of.
You think it's still alive?
It's one of those bigger poodles.
You know,
like the George Meichin have poodles.
You know those big ones are actually really good at Frisbee.
They actually become a dog when they get that big.
All right,
where the fuck is it?
You fucking whore.
Don't be like this.
I don't fucking know.
I told you basically where it is and it's on the fucking west side of the
street.
Anyways,
I had a god Damn Burrito.
I'm still thinking about it.
And here I am in the middle of the podcast doing one of the most boring things I
could possibly do is,
which is search for the thing.
That's how good this fucking Burrito was.
I'm literally stocking it just so I can look on stand outside the window via my
fucking laptop.
Um,
all right.
That was excruciatingly boring.
And if this podcast wasn't free,
I'd fucking apologize for it.
Uh,
[inaudible] so,
hey,
I'm going to let her hear for some,
a fan from Alaska.
All right.
Do you ever hear that expression where they say you can't run from your
problems?
Well,
uh,
tell people in Alaska,
because most people up there are wanted,
you know,
and not in a good way.
Mike,
we really love you to come back to South Dakota.
They are wanted in uh,
one of those,
you know,
those fucking idiots,
those spur of the moment,
bank robbers.
We standing there and the only reason why you rob the bank was because the line
was just long enough to give you enough time to think like,
you know what?
I could always rob this fucking bank and if there was no one in front of you,
you just want it gone in and found out what,
you know,
what your balance was.
But there was just,
you know,
seven people in front of you.
You started working out the whole thing.
You know,
the fuck's going on.
Look at everybody.
We all work every single day in every week.
They give us a check.
They don't give us cash.
They give us these numbers on a piece of paper.
What do we deal with that we take it right down to these clients.
We give them all our money.
You know,
it's,
is this,
I feel like a fucking hooker right now.
I went out and I worked all right.
I get my money in this form of fucking currency that I can't,
I can't even use unless I go to you.
You fucking asshole.
And then you keep the shit.
I got to stick it in there and you give it out to be $20.
If time telling me everything's going to be okay,
I want you to know something.
I would love to go to a bank where they actually had the nerve to walk around
and like purple sparkly suits with big feathers,
you know,
driving Lincoln continentals from 1975.
Just dress like the fucking pimp that you are.
I'll give a shit.
I'll doll myself up to go in there and try and get my money.
You fucking cons.
So anyways,
this is a,
uh,
um,
a letter from a crazy Alaskan fan set up.
Bill,
I bought,
let it go on iTunes.
Thank you.
Um,
earlier this evening and had,
uh,
quite the fucking goat rope.
I don't know what that means.
I'm sure that means like,
I was freaking out in Alaska.
I had quite the fucking goat rope.
The fuck would that the Italia go to your cabin up there.
Goats eat everything.
I don't get it.
Crazy Alaskan fan.
Can you please explain that to me?
I don't know.
You had quite the fucking goat rope.
Okay.
That doesn't sound like it was good.
Um,
anyways,
I live out in the middle of BFE Alaska.
I don't know what that means.
Either set up an area or is that bum fucking East Alaska,
I dunno and have no need for the Internet in my Ted Kaczynski cabin.
According to Mark Marin on Twitter,
uh,
Ted Kaczynski is a cabin is actually for sale.
Um,
but I digress.
Here we go.
Continuing my neighbor who is down the road has,
has the Internet and if I sit,
my laptop's sideways facing due south on the very top of my Warren commission
volumes,
I can connect at tip top 1997 speed.
I only do this once a month.
So I went on iTunes and I bought,
let it go,
Joe to roses album,
the depression auction and some Chuck Berry that you got great taste too.
Great Comedians and one of the greatest guitarists of all time.
Um,
all right,
Michael Graves.
I Dunno what that,
if I'm saying that right,
and the latest iron maiden effort,
I picked all the tunes out that I wanted sat my laptop on.
It's seven foot perch on its side so I could download,
let it go.
So I let it download all that shit.
All right.
I sat down and out of the corner of my eye I saw Sarah McLaughlin written on the
screen and I immediately thought,
Oh fuck,
I somehow hit the wrong button and I fucking bought some Sarah McLaughlin Song.
Uh,
so I grabbed the for the computer and there it went right down the to the
fucking floor,
seven feet down onto a linoleum for boom.
I started screaming at the top of my lungs about that concern Mclaughlin and
those prick bastards that I tuned for faking me out and making me buy that dumb
shit.
I was really freaking out.
I opened my front door to cool off and they are four feet in front of me was a
big brown bear looking at me like I was some kind of asshole.
I grabbed the door and ran like hell back in liquid lickety split lickety split.
And that's the kind of fucking expression you use if you live in a camp.
Fucking goat rope.
Lickety split.
Uh,
my heart was beating like crazy.
I was surprised to see,
and I walked up to my computer and I was surprised to see that my screen was
okay on the laptop.
It fired right up away.
Holy Shit.
It works.
When I reloaded Itunes I saw,
or Sarah McLaughlin was actually one of the comedy cuts on,
let it go.
Uh,
I let it go.
All right,
you're crazy.
Alaskan Fan,
Pete Jesus Christ piece.
It sounds like some shit I would do.
You guys do that a lot.
Do you absolutely lose your shit?
You know,
you build up some,
some sort of conspiracy in your fucking head and then you realize in the end
that you were actually wrong,
you know?
But in that moment,
you by yourself
and you try to blow it off by turning the car radio on and try to drown out that
voice,
that screaming voice in your head and that feeling of embarrassment that you,
you are actually the Douche bag and then you just wasted the last whatever,
five,
seven minutes of your life.
Absolute flipping out about some shit that you know really didn't,
didn't even fucking happen or maybe some shit that you created.
If you did,
then you can relate to the first 37 years of my life people.
Cause that's what the fuck I did to get my goddamn fingernails.
I need to cut my fingernails.
I've been on the road too,
God damn long get guys who said,
okay,
if I just tap out,
can I just,
you know,
you know what I feel like right now when you guys are at work and you just don't
want to be there.
So then you just,
you start faking sick.
You know,
you get that Douchey look on your face.
just,
you know,
you just start speaking in a Wayne East.
Suffolk ain't really,
excuse me.
Path.
Excuse me.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know if it's something I ate.
I started feeling like this the other day.
You guys have to give it credibility.
I started feeling this way the other day.
Really?
You were pretty fucking chipper when he came walking in,
you know?
Can I tell you guys about that coke head I used to work with a long time ago.
He used to come walking into the warehouse like four hours late on a sunny day
with his hair soak and wet from a shower and his excuse was always the same.
Oh,
the traffic traffic was unbelievable.
Really?
It's fucking 92 degrees out there,
buddy with you're soaking wet hair.
I don't even know if it was from a shower.
It could have been like that drug sweat.
What time I was doing the opion Anthony's show and they had some guys,
some fucking rock band guys in there that were the shit,
I'm not gonna fucking blow up this spot and say their name because it was like
eight 30 in the morning when they came.
And we interviewed him for like an hour and at nine 30 in the morning I asked
the lead singer if I can get a picture with them.
And he goes,
sure.
He fucking pulled me into him and his head's fucking side of his face up against
my side of the face.
And it was just,
I don't know what it was.
Flop sweat,
drug,
sweat,
meth,
sweats.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
But you have,
have you ever fucking played basketball?
And you play shirts and skins and the fatty.
Not only you got to cover the fatty,
but he fucking is skins and they're in their transition games and you fucking,
you're standing there and the paint and that fatty goes running by you and you
feel like,
ah,
like somebody just emptied a Jacuzzi on you.
That's what it felt like was fucking disgusting.
Oh,
wait a minute.
There it is.
There's the Burrito spot.
It's called Gordo,
There we go.
There we go on ninth avenue in Irving.
Just walk North on Ninth Avenue.
Irving street.
Who's the fucking shit?
It's one of those things.
If I was like Elvis Presley,
you know,
hi my ass.
Go get a fucking Burrito,
man.
I'm all hopped up on coil leaves and shit.
I want to fucking Burrito man.
I would get him a private jet and Van Nuys and I'd fly like nine of my friends
up who don't really like me and at that point that just there for the money and
they're laughing at all my jokes,
like I'm the funniest fuck or ever,
you know.
Hey man,
where'd you get those shoes at a shoe store.
And they're all like,
wow,
good man,
you killed us.
The kilos on.
Oh Man.
Everything I say it's funny.
Everything.
Every sing I sing is a fucking hit.
Let's go get a fucking burrito.
That stewardess,
she thinks she'll suck my dick.
Everybody laughing like sexual sexual harassment didn't exist back then.
If you sold enough fucking records in the 70s sexual harassment didn't exist in
the 60s yeah,
you could just,
you could just rip somebody if you want to hit record,
if anybody complains.
Ah,
pipe down.
How many albums did you sell there sweetheart?
So brutal fucking time to be a female,
you know,
so we had to correct it and the only way we knew we would have known,
we never would have found out if those ladies didn't start burning their bras.
How many of those fucking ex hippies do you think that regret that moment?
Standing in the street?
What?
What exactly was their fucking problem with the Brazil?
You know,
what do you want?
You want your titties hanging down to your waist.
You don't want that.
The number one fucking thing that gets you some shit.
Little things during the course of the day.
Oh Man.
Would you like to go first?
Go ahead.
You think I'm being a gentleman?
I'm not being a gentleman.
It's cause you have perky titties.
All right?
And you have the fucking decency to only button your shirt right up to just
below your cleavage.
And because of that,
yes,
madam,
you can go before me.
If I had a hat,
I would take it off and I would bend over at the waist like,
like,
like one of those three musketeers,
you know,
throw my fucking coat down over a puddle of water.
You know,
there you are ma'am.
Right?
It's cause he had titties.
What keeps your titties perky ladies?
What keeps him?
Yeah.
Side for meeting steamed vegetables instead of a quarter pounder with cheese.
Come on.
We all know it's your God damn.
[inaudible].
All right,
Si.
Fucking the Sports Bra.
Whatever the fuck you want.
If you want to keep those babies high and tight.
All right.
I know it's hard for you to hear this from a man.
It's coming off showed chauvinist sticker,
right?
But if I was,
you know,
some fucking motivational speaker and I was a female standing up here saying the
exact same shit,
but I had a clam,
you'd be less than,
you'd be listening.
You buy my stupid books and I'd have those fucking arms smart glasses on,
you know,
you know those women dress,
they walked that fine line to have enough business suit on,
but they still look like,
you know,
I'll fuck the shit out of you.
You know that look,
exactly.
Speaking of that,
you guys seen that fucking,
I'm walking around right now.
I gotta stand up.
Let the funny fall down.
Wash over me.
You guys watch that show up.
I don't know what the hell it's called,
but you know what I mean?
That's it's,
it stars this woman.
Um,
it's Kinda like that Shane,
I'll let show that bald guy screaming about the stocks and he's throwing stuffed
animals around and for some stupid fucking reason,
people that I know why people listen because he's loud.
He's passionate.
I've made a fucking career out of that.
If you just say my jokes without screaming them and working up a sweat,
I don't think that funny.
You know,
the true masters to build bill Cosby can sit in a lawn chair and killed for two
straight hours.
I couldn't do that.
Jesus Christ.
If I sat down for two hours to try to tell jokes,
just the sound of my own voice with,
they'd put me asleep,
forget about the fucking crowd.
But anyways,
so I'm watching the show late night cause I'm not drinking,
you know,
staying in his fucking hotel down on Jefferson Street and hide the Apocalypto,
whatever the fuck it's called.
You know,
it's funny.
I think I took a picture too.
I'm going to put it on the MLM,
podcast.com for some fucking reason.
Did you guys ever see that movie a Shaka Zulu?
Is that the name of it?
Chuck a Zulu,
Shaka Zulu Zulu for Hulu,
whatever the fuck it's called,
right?
It was basically about a,
Ah,
gee,
I know what the fuck was imposed by an English guys in Africa.
And they went down there and uh,
they took over some shit and the Zulu nation and had enough.
Right.
And they are,
they all stood on the fucking hill and that the,
there's slamming their fucking weapons against their,
uh,
their shields there.
It's the Shit,
you know,
Michael Caine and all those guys,
remember how they were dressed?
No stupid white hats.
I don't know what,
I don't know what it looked like.
You know what it looked like?
Do you guys ever watched bonanza?
Remember that Guy Hos or that 10 gallon fucking hatchets?
Imagine if you had that hat,
but you cut the brim off of it.
He just left that big stupid hat on.
Amy.
You've got a little bit of a brim on the front and on the back.
Like if,
uh,
what do you call those?
Those little hats.
You know those little hats that fucking people were like Charlie Chaplin.
Just imagine if that had,
could get an erection right in the fucking brim was the balls.
So you know that just fucking stay in the same,
that's what the hat look like.
Okay.
For some fucked up reason.
The,
the,
as I say,
the guards the do to stand outside on the sidewalk and go,
hey,
can I help you with that bag that you obviously carried here with no problems so
I can possibly make a couple of dollars.
Those guys,
the doorman,
they go,
they were dressed like those fucking Englishman and Shaka Zulu or chuck or Zulu,
Zulu,
Hulu,
whatever the fuck it's called.
I don't know why I thought to need to bring that up.
Let's talk about the hotel.
They had a wine tasting place right next door,
you know,
which just attracts soccer moms.
It's fucking ridiculous.
You know those God damn brides,
when they get older,
they have a couple of kids,
they can't go out and do keg stands with their,
who ha hanging out of their panties anymore.
They're a fucking mom.
So they gotta be,
you know,
they've got to be more mature with their drinking.
So they go out to places like those little,
those wine bars.
Music isn't too loud,
you know,
it doesn't make their tits quiver.
Right.
So they can sit down,
sit down with their friends,
they have cheese,
they got wine,
and they could sit there and discuss shit,
you know,
and act like they're fucking adults rather than just scared teenagers with
children.
Um,
the fuck.
So I had to walk by that shit all the time.
And evidently one of these broads had too much to drink.
I don't know what somebody's fucking yakked on my floor.
It was cleaned up before I got there,
but she know that,
you know,
once somebody pukes them as just going to be there,
it's going to be there for,
we need,
you need a new rug.
Who's Ken Hill?
All right.
Few puke enough.
They really need to tear down the building.
So anyways,
I know how I got on that fucking subject,
but this is good man.
It got a little bit of momentum.
I stood up filling.
All right.
Oh,
I know what I was talking about.
I was talking about that lady I was watching on the show.
So,
uh,
I'm not drinking saw back in the hotel where the dude's address,
like the fucking apartheid Englishman at the door and somebody yakked on my
floor.
I'm sitting there watching this fucking show.
That's how I got there.
All right,
so I'm watching the show and a flipping through the channels and watching TV and
I'm flipping through the fucking channels.
I'm losing all my goddamn bet.
Someone one in three this week.
Um,
and I'm flipping through the fucking channels and I stop on this show
and it's this lady,
I don't know what her deal is,
but like adults call her up and say,
I want to buy this.
Can I afford it?
You know,
like they're fucking eight years old
just calling.
Hey isn't,
isn't this is jail.
I'm counting from Arkansas for thoughts will tell you I love your show.
I absolutely love it.
Me and my husband,
we it all the time.
We absolutely love it.
We think you're great.
And you know,
a lot of people probably think that you put too much bleach in your teeth,
especially with that orange fake Tan,
you know,
so you look like that fucking plant in little shop of horrors.
But that's not me.
I think you look great,
right?
They go through all that bullshit.
So this bitch calls up and go,
why do I say that?
I never talked to women that way.
So this lady says,
I want a fucking,
uh,
I want,
I want to buy a,
I want to buy a fucking condo down in Florida.
Do I have enough money?
Y'All haven't,
can I afford it?
That's what the fuck she said called up.
This complete fucking stranger says,
I want to buy a condo and as this other fucking complete fucking strange,
can I afford it?
It's like,
did you mail this woman all your bank records like five fucking years ago and
you haven't,
you have no fucking idea how much money you have.
You dumped cons,
Jesus,
and what the whole fucking hour was.
Hey,
my name's Mike call calling in from Rhode Island.
Let's shit.
I want to get a tattoo on my fucking ball bag,
but I also want to cut out the ropes so I can get t tarps.
Oh my fucking 85 rally sport.
Can I afford to do that?
That's what the show was.
This woman telling adults
who had jobs and lives and probably children,
whether or not they could afford something.
It just really was.
You know,
I was one of those times where it's just like,
you know what,
there's not enough lightning in the world.
You know?
Just as far as the odds of being struck by lightning.
We need to bring that average up because the amount of fucking morons out there
versus actually intelligent people,
you're going to hit a fucking moron,
you know basically going to hit a moron or are you going to hit the ocean?
Those are going to be the top two in that order.
Even though the fucking world is three quarters fucking water,
you still got a higher chance as lightening to fucking hit a moron.
That's that.
That's,
I'm telling you.
That's my goddamn theory and that's what I want the new stat to be.
Rather than being like,
you know the,
the odds of getting hit by lightning or higher of then blah,
blah,
blah.
I want it to turn into,
I want so much lightening that,
that,
that the new stat is the odds of an intelligent person actually being hit by
lightning are x,
y,
and Z.
Do you like how in my own little style and esque world that I'm actually
intelligent and everybody else is just a sea of morons?
Huh?
You don't have thoughts like that.
Murderous thoughts.
I was actually talking to this broad up in San Francisco and
I got this whole chunk about hitting women that I've been doing on stage and uh,
it's actually something embarrassing I have to admit about myself as much as I,
the,
the comedy thing for a living.
I'm really bad at picking up on sarcasm.
I'm just,
I don't know why I use sarcasm.
I'm sarcastic,
right?
But for some reason when someone uses it against me,
I,
I've just like that old guy downstairs.
But if I told you that shit last year when I was dragging my Christmas tree down
the stairs,
he stuck his head out the window and he just goes,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
And he had this fucked up look on his face,
but he said,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
So I was confused and I just want,
yeah,
there's a beautiful morning.
I'll pick a,
why is he yelling with that,
twist that up,
look in his face.
And then I walked around the corner.
I was like,
oh,
he didn't mean it.
He,
what he really meant was she making a lot of fucking noise ruining this
beautiful morning.
So he got me.
Then I always end up feeling stupid.
So you know,
I'm doing this whole chunk on hitting the broads over there.
Right.
And I'm standing afterwards whoring myself out,
right.
Sell on my DVD,
shown a little bit of leg doing what I gotta do.
And this fucking woman is walking out and her husband is sort of shuffling her
out and she starts going,
ah,
oh yeah,
she,
she has once again the twist it up,
look on her face.
She goes,
thanks for the domestic violence jokes.
I really appreciated it.
I really appreciated the domestic violence jugs.
Thanks a lot for the domestic violence jokes.
That's what she was doing.
And because she was saying thanks,
it just,
it went totally pass my head.
I was more just confused by her facial expressions.
So she said,
oh yeah,
I really appreciated it.
Thanks a lot.
I'm literally just waving,
gone.
Alright,
glad you enjoy the show.
Which is funny because it probably pissed her off more,
but I was sincerely thanking her completely missing her sarcasm.
What she was really saying was ivy the dealt with that personally,
or that's happening to somebody right now or has happened to someone or I grew
up with it or whatever,
and you brought up bad memories and you ruined my fucking evening.
That's what she was really saying.
But of course I took it at face value,
which actually when I look back on it,
I think makes it even funnier because who's kidding who?
She already thinks I'm a fucking moron at that point,
you know?
So it would actually would have made her a little bit happier if I tried to
appear intelligent.
If like actually you missed the point of the Geo Code.
It was really trying to do is expose the hypocrisy of some of the relationships
between the male and female fixes.
If I went that route,
you know?
Yeah.
Then she could have gotten this hot.
But the fact that I literally was the moron that she thought I was,
and then that there was this whole line of people,
you know what,
I just realized I should be struck by lightning.
Where the fuck is wrong with me?
I'm one of those fucking morons.
Um,
all right,
so there's that portion of the fucking program that's 36 minutes.
Do it.
I'm not this,
no way.
I'm going more than 50 minutes.
I gotta make a judgment call here.
Like,
uh,
I'm trying to find some friends where I can watch his patriots jets game.
Cause I,
I,
I can't go out and watch just regular games at a sports bar unless it's a team I
don't give a fuck about.
But there's no way a game like this that I care so much about.
Um,
I know too,
a lot of people,
this is going to be a huge fucking game,
which obviously it is,
but I gotta be honest with you.
I,
I'm not feeling our defense.
I really want to talk some shit,
but I gotta be honest with you.
Okay?
You guys want to hear my big prediction?
I'm going to go on a limb here rather than all these other fucking assholes who
email me after the game and don't make any sort of predictions.
This is my prediction.
I think
obviously you guys know I don't like our fucking defense,
but I got up and I gotta tell you this,
we have no fucking pass rush and the jets haven't fucking incredible offensive
line.
Those guys are the shit.
So what's his face?
Sanchez is going to be sitting back there like bill Cosby doing a standup
special.
Um,
and then you combine the fact that we have a shit defense that lets up 24 to 30
fucking points a game.
I don't like that aspect of it,
but I believe in our offense.
I think our offense is great,
but they have a great defense.
So I dunno,
I just really see this being one of those 28 to 17,
you know,
don't listen to my gambling tips,
but if I was gambling,
I actually had to put money on this.
It was my last fucking 100 bucks.
I would,
I would take the jets in the fucking points.
But,
uh,
but if the Patriots to win because we got fucking Tom Brady,
we have the genius of Bill Belichick who can somehow figure out a way during the
second half to come back.
I think,
uh,
even if they win,
I still don't think it means shit other than that.
We've come a long way since September,
but we'd still have to,
I think write,
we'd still have to play
the J.
I don't know.
Then if the playoffs came around,
I had a play offs.
I don't know.
This game is going to be fucking awesome.
Plus you also got to look at,
but uh,
Rex Ryan has Buddy Ryan at his fingertips,
so this doesn't,
this is going to be a fucking awesome game.
This is really going to be an awesome game and I am going to age at least eight
fucking years.
I'm not going to be able to handle it.
Like I gotta tell you some games like this,
how fucking psycho I get.
Like I give a shit so much.
Sometimes I taped the game and I don't even watch it.
And then I just find out if my team wins,
then I'll sit down and watch it.
But if they lose,
I just fucking erase the game because that's how much it affects me,
you know?
And I know what you think.
Oh,
what are you a fucking pussy?
Yes.
I don't know if I'm pushing you from fucking intelligent,
it's like I don't want,
I don't want to waste that amount of my fucking life.
I don't want to care that much in it,
but I do.
So I tried to protect myself.
Oh,
so let me tell you guys about San Francisco.
If you go into San Francisco,
if you're going to San Francisco,
um,
here's some shit to know.
Uh,
their public transportation system takes,
it takes a minute to kind of get to figure it out.
They have like all these different subway lines that they're like street cars
and then they go under ground.
They all sort of funnel inter down there.
The Union Square area,
the Union Square area,
as far as I can tell,
is the most touristy fucking place.
Like the Times Square of San Francisco in that,
I don't think anybody from San Francisco goes there.
I think people from Oakland go in it.
Douche bags like me go down there before they figure out like,
oh,
this place sucks.
But,
uh,
I actually,
if the line's not too long and you can jump on one of those rice,
a Roni trolleys and he can go all the way up to fucking north beach and hang on,
who do we got here?
Ah,
Jesus.
He says the guy's calling about the game.
Hey Ben,
I'm doing my podcast.
Let me call you back in like 20 minutes.
All right,
right.
Cool.
Um,
all right.
Yeah.
So I don't know if you go there with your girl,
there's all the shops at down there,
so you're gonna want to go,
they already told you where to get a burrito.
Actually,
if you just want to go to Burrito ground central,
go to go to a,
the mission district.
And this is just for people if you're going to San Francisco.
And then there's just all kinds of fucking awesome bars.
And I actually was staying.
Uh,
you know what?
It fucking rained the entire time I was there.
Where else did I go?
I got some decent Italian food.
I went to that place,
Mama's for breakfast.
I wasn't really impressed,
but I got French toast and I figured most people don't.
You know,
something that's something that a lot of people don't know how to make.
I can actually make better French toast then.
Most of the fucking assholes out there.
You know,
they just don't do it right.
They just don't fucking do it right.
The bread just doesn't taste right.
I go old fashioned way.
My mom used to make it,
you know,
he actually use white bread that Wonderbread shit.
And I know it's a lower quality meat,
a fucking bread than they use.
But I'm telling you,
sometimes you can overthink something.
He get to fucking fancy.
Like I'll tell you right now,
you go out and make yourself a fried egg.
You fried up and butter.
All right.
Fuck the surgeon general.
Every once in a,
you got to tell that guy to stand the fuck down.
All right,
sit down.
Oh man,
I'm cooking this shit and butter,
right?
You stupid fucking half a beard,
sergeant general looks like he already fucking die.
Did he die?
We had that like,
like he was the commander in chief of all love boats.
Steph fucking uniform.
Um,
so whatever you fry it up in butter.
All right.
You Cook it over Eg.
Take it easy.
All right.
Cook it over easy.
I don't know how to fuck you guys do a porn.
I do something over easy.
I fucking uh,
I turned the egg once.
All right,
after I cook the fucking egg and I get it to the consistency.
I want what?
I cook it on low heat too,
by the way.
Russia cooked Christ your cook the shit out of it.
Um,
you cook it on a low heat,
right?
And then once you do is once you get it,
look in the way you want it to look.
Y'All see,
you put your salt and pepper on the top right as it's fucking cooking in the
butter.
Then you flip it over and the second you flip it over,
you take it off the heat.
All right?
And you let,
how hot the uh,
the pan already is cooked the other side.
All right,
so almost like marketing stake.
That's how you do the other side.
That way you get the,
you know the egg isn't runny,
you know,
but you still got the yolk there.
All right?
Oh,
that's how I make an egg over easy.
But if I'm making a fucking fried egg,
you know,
you got to cook a thing over hard.
Same Shit.
You're cook it in butter.
Sit the fuck down old man.
He kicked you cook it in butter and he'd do that.
All that bullshit and he just,
you want wonder bread.
Do you want the shittiest fucking bread ever?
All right.
That kind of shit.
It's,
you're not going to digest.
He like 62 slices a bread.
All right,
you salt and pepper.
That bitch.
She cook it and fucking butter.
You put it on the God damn sandwich and he put a little mustard on top of it.
Nothing fucking fancy that,
that grey poupon shit.
I'm talking broke ass white trash.
Fucking my mustard.
All right.
Yellow plastic container comes out yellow like mustard.
Should be not that golden shit.
None of that stuff.
Straight up.
All right?
You fucking,
you know,
put that bitch on a plate and you go to Tom's delicious,
straight up fucking comfort food,
all those fucking places.
I don't know why they don't just make shit like that.
Just,
you know,
it's like the Mcdonald's concept,
but you actually use sort of real food.
I was speaking to that,
you know,
when I was walking through Haight Ashbury or the hate,
you don't want to get a fucking look like,
oh,
you're a tourist.
Just say,
I want to go to the hate.
How did we get to the hate?
Right?
You go to fucking in that.
I don't,
what the fuck?
I still feel stupid saying that.
Uh,
but you go out there,
you know,
and that's where all the dirty white people are,
Amy,
and can you spirits from fucking change me in?
They got dreadlocks and shit.
You know,
they're dirty fucking wrangler jeans from sitting on the fucking sidewalk.
I really am reverse racist when it comes to fucking
white homeless people,
you know?
Okay.
If you're white and you're fucking homeless and you're under the age of 62
you're not getting a fucking dime out of me.
You're just not unless you,
maybe if you're a female,
then he got that look.
You know you've got that right.
Look,
I'll do it,
you know?
But other than that,
it's like,
come on man,
seriously get a fucking job.
You're a fucking white tube.
Go get a fucking job.
I really should be making those jokes in this economy.
I apologize,
but you know what I'm saying?
All right,
talking about,
I'm not talking about you.
If you're out of work right now and you looking for a job,
hang in there.
I fucking respect.
You're right.
But I'm talking about those other bumps.
Talking about bumps in their twenties all right,
this is a deal.
If you're white,
if you look like boxcar Willie,
you know you've got to stick with that little current chief tad to it.
I'll give you some money.
You know,
if you can stick him knows in your mouth because you don't have any fucking
teeth,
I'll give you some money,
you know?
But as far as the rest of the people go,
you get money out of me.
If you look like you're sober,
other than that,
you can go fuck yourself,
whatever.
Hap Who,
what,
who does shit like this and December,
this is what all saint nick is coming down the fucking tube.
Right?
Oh,
you better watch out.
You better not cry.
You better not pout up telling you why Santa Claus is coming to town.
Um,
you know,
did I tell you guys,
I went up to a,
I went to this observatory and I was looking at stars the other night cause I'm
not fucking drinking and I'm desperately trying to fill these hours.
When I used to have fun in my life and uh,
I was looking at the moons of Jupiter and uh,
one of the moons was named after some fucking,
um,
let's see if I have the information here was named after,
what the fuck would I think?
Like,
you know what,
I can wing this.
You guys don't need to know the name.
You don't give a fuck.
One of the moons of Jupiter is named after a,
Jupiter was basically the Roman Zeus,
right when it comes to mythology,
if I remember correctly,
they basically stole other gods like stealing like a fucking script idea.
They just changed up the names of the characters like,
Nah man,
it's different when you talking about,
so Jupiter was married to a,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck her name was.
Apollonia right.
We're just gonna use fake names here.
And they had a daughter named die,
Heather,
her Helena,
I don't know what the fuck her name was.
One of the moons is named after this girl now evidently,
uh,
this is how this,
this is how the story goes in mythology,
is
Jupiter had basically a crush on his own fucking daughter and his wife,
rather than reporting it to the proper authorities,
was just simply jealous.
Like he was banging some hottie down the street rather than her fucking
daughter.
So Jupiter is banging his own daughter.
His wife gets wind of it,
he gets fucking nervous.
So he turns her into a cow,
not his wife.
He turns his beautiful daughter that he was banging into a Heifer Heifer
evidently is a fucking a fucking cow that doesn't give an a calf yet.
You know,
it's ready to be fucking banged raw dog style,
right?
That's a fucking story.
I swear to God,
if all you,
Jesus freaks out there who are looking down your nose at that sort of mythical
mythology,
you'll fucking religion starts to same goddamn way.
Adam and Eve,
first two fucking people,
they were hanging out.
Somehow they became more people.
It's really weird.
Like that guy was basically,
this guy told this fucking story or at least brought it up.
I guess he didn't tell the whole story.
Then I researched it.
It's just the,
um,
the incest,
you was the acceptance of incest back in the day.
I don't know if it's creepy or if it just makes sense.
You know,
you gotta be,
you gotta be asking yourself this.
All right.
There's only 40 people on the planet.
All right,
let's just say 25 of them are women.
15 of a woman that doesn't even add up does it?
Is 40 care does 25 and 15 is 40 see that we all learned something here today on
the podcast.
All right?
Let's say
let's say 15 or men in 25 are fucking women.
All right?
Now who's kidding?
Who you been to a bar?
Does 25 fucking women in there?
All right.
How many of them could you completely give a shit?
About 12 good.
Half of them.
You don't give a fuck.
You stone sober.
Yeah,
whatever with you fucking jeans beat it.
All right?
You got weird eyebrows.
Get the fuck away from me.
I don't care.
It's a 12 of them are out the window.
Now you're down to 13 women.
How many of them are going to be hot?
Let's use the bar analogy.
There's going to be about four hot once.
All right,
not this.
25 women in 15 guys and only four of those women.
A fucking hot is a good God damn chance that one of those women is going to be
your daughter.
No laws have been made about it.
You know there's no real Saudi.
We know they haven't even invented the fucking wheel yet or the hammer.
There's no does,
no jurisdiction is known jurisdiction.
There's no laws.
I guess that that's why it made sense.
Like why all these religions started that way.
And then Thor banged his sister in front of his daughter and Nope,
nobody the shit.
So anyways,
I dunno what the fuck I'm talking about here.
People,
I'm just trying to get to 50 and it's 51 minutes.
45 seconds bump up,
bump up,
vote up bone up to the door to do.
Uh,
it's time to go watch Monday night football.
Everybody.
All right,
let's hope we have a nice fair game.
I got a lot of balls saying that as a patriots fan.
Um,
anyways,
I'm looking forward to this.
I don't like it.
I don't have a good fucking feeling.
I just,
I don't like it.
But what's great is,
is I had a feeling that I was going to go undefeated this week,
four no,
with my picks and I went one and three.
So,
uh,
the odds have it that the fact that I think the jets are going to win means my
patriots might win.
Right?
Does that make any fucking sense?
All right.
Listen to this fuck faces.
I'm going to upload this thing and I'm going to put up some pictures that I took
when I was in San Francisco.
How hilarious is that?
You know,
it's like all of a sudden,
I'm not drinking on the road and now,
now I'm taking pictures like Goddamn tourists,
and I'm telling you how to fry a fucking egg.
I don't know if I like it,
but I'm 51 days,
then I'm definitely gonna drink again.
Um,
I just need to learn to do it in moderation so my head doesn't get all big and
fat.
All right,
well,
that's the podcast this week.
You guys all have a wonderful week.
I hope all your dreams come true and go fuck yourself.
Okay?
[inaudible].